[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors comme l'a dit ça là peut-être vous
m'avez vu à la télé et peut-être vous
avez eu vent de mon histoire et de ce
qui m'est arrivé ou peut-être même pas
du tout mais du coup laissez-moi vous
raconter aujourd'hui mon histoire parce
que je pense que c'est peut-être aussi
en partie la vôtre
alors je suis née et j'ai grandi à la
campagne avec mes sœurs et j'ai toujours
aimé la nature ça m'arrivait des fois de
parler à la lune et aux étoiles et
j'imaginais leur réponse
d'un père syrien et d'une mère marocaine
j'ai baigné dans une culture arabe au
musulmane
aussi j'ai toujours aimé la musique et
quand j'étais petite je voulais chanter
et voyager autour du monde
alors à 12 ans en économisant je me suis
acheté mon tout premier piano
j'ai fait de sa référence tous mes mots
de passe internet c'était je m'en
souviens un Yamaha YT 200
mais j'ai quand même changé les mots de
passe depuis je vous rassure
et enfin c'est pour vous dire à quel
point j'étais heureuse d'avoir un
meilleur ami parce que j'étais une
enfant certes sociale mais je me sentais
souvent incomprise donc avec ce piano
des années quelques années plus tard
j'écris ma propre chaîne Youtube où je
partageais mes reprises de chansons de
cover
accompagné de mon piano depuis ma
chambre et ma famille elle n'était pas
au courant
au lycée à 16 ans il y avait un concours
de talent qui était organisé et j'ai une
amie qui a mis mon nom en secret sur la
liste de passages
et là j'entends qu'on m'appelle au micro
je deviens toute rouge et je me fais
pousser pour aller chanter devant tout
le monde dans la cour
c'était juste incroyable pour moi
c'était la première fois que j'avais des
compliments
or que moi que mon piano en fait que ma
chambre et là
j'ai adoré mais j'en ai pas parlé à mes
parents parce que j'avais peur qu'on me
décourage encore une fois je cultivais
un jardin secret je gardais la musique
comme un exutoire très très intime
et puis à 18 ans je
décide de porter le voile puis le turban
c'était pour me pour mes convictions
religieuses et aussi pour me sentir
appartenir à ma famille que tout le
monde soit centraka et j'ai toujours été
tiré entre la volonté de suivre ce que
ma famille la société attend de moi ou
bien celle de suivre mon intuition
alors après mon bac je suis je poursuis
à la fac pour faire des études de
langues et tout était routine jusqu'à la
troisième année où je décide de partir
en Erasmus et je pars en Suède aucune
idée de pourquoi la Suède c'était comme
ça
et là mes parents ben mon nom dissuadés
mais je voulais vraiment découvrir je
voulais vraiment voyager et je suis
quelqu'un de très tenace donc je voulais
absolument partir
je pars en Suède pour un an et et puis
là je me redécouvre je fais des vidéos à
la fac de musicologie je voyage toute
seule
vraiment je crée un environnement qui me
ressemble et là la musique vient
réenchanter mon monde parce que je me
retrouve avec moi ma musique et le
voyage
également je tombe amoureuse d'un
suédois afghan et
et
puis l'histoire se passe très bien et
l'année se termine j'en parle à mes
parents et là non c'est c'est un nom
donc on me dit il faut que tu rentres en
France tu reprends tes études en Master
et puis voilà reprendre ta vie normale
d'accord alors j'ai fait ça je suis
rentrée en France j'ai rompu ma relation
le cœur serré et j'ai repris des études
en Master là je me retrouve donc en
master en 2016 et
je il y a ma chaîne Youtube qui est
toujours active et je lis un commentaire
sur sous une de mes vidéos où on me
propose d'auditionner pour une émission
la fameuse émission The Voice France
je me dis c'est pas vrai c'est une
blague mais et si c'était vrai par
contre et que c'était l'occasion pour
moi de sortir de ma chambre et de est-ce
que peut-être il y a pas une autre voix
pour moi
donc je j'envoie ma candidature et un an
plus tard je suis sélectionnée
je j'en parle encore une fois à personne
je regarde ça très secret je fais les
allers-retours pour aller à Paris et là
la magie opère je passe une étape deux
étapes trois étapes je suis sélectionnée
pour les lives et je me dis bah il
serait quand même temps d'en parler
parce qu'on va me voir à la télé je peux
plus trop me cacher donc février 2018
arrive le jour de la diffusion j'en
parle une semaine avant
c'est dire la surprise et on est tous
devant le poste de télé et on attend mon
passage ce samedi là c'est le prime time
sur TF1 et je chante donc
alléluia en anglais et en arabe et là
c'est les quatre coachs qui se
retournent
c'était vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc les quatre coachs se retournent
j'étais chez moi avec mes parents et là
mon téléphone
sonne sonne j'ai vraiment ça se passait
en 24 heures les 24 heures qui ont suivi
ça à la télé mon téléphone a sonné sonné
et je recevais des tonnes de messages
donc de félicitations et là je vois des
messages de haine vraiment j'ai pas
compris donc le débat il portait sur un
post Facebook que j'avais publié il y a
quatre ans auparavant et sur le fait que
j'avais un turban
alors après tout ça je me dis stop je
vais faire une pause et là
un jeune Américain de un jeune Américain
d'origine arabe mais écrit sur Instagram
et
donc le courant passe très très bien
à ce moment là j'écris plus je chante
plus je veux juste m'éloigner vraiment
de tout ça de mon pays de la musique et
lui il me console et puis bah évidemment
on tombe amoureux et puis alors il me
dit bah tiens rejoins-moi aux États-Unis
pour 3 semaines qu'on
se voit je pars pour trois semaines et
à mon retour en France donc quelques
mois plus tard on décide de se financer
on se fiance pour un mariage plus tard
religieux
et puis
au début
tout se passait bien je je
après l'union je me dis bon ben je vais
aller m'installer avec lui carrément aux
États-Unis allez donc je pars je pars à
Denver au début tout se passait vraiment
bien je m'imaginais une vie un peu à
l'américaine donc le chien la pelouse
verte les deux enfants et surtout une
vie un peu à la dépression
donc j'essaie vraiment de me conformer à
une vie normale plus de musique plus
rien sauf que il y avait toujours cet
appel de la musique en moi et je faisais
le choix de l'ignorer parce que mais
pourtant j'avais mal parce que j'étais
encore une fois en train de de moto
censurer
alors je faisais ça pour avoir la paix
mais cette peine n'a pas duré parce
qu'en 2018 je reçois là une invitation
royale le vrai terme royal
il s'agissait d'une invitation à venir
chanter en Jordanie pour le roi à
l'occasion de Noël
donc ça c'est c'était le jour où j'ai
chanté et je sers à la main du roi et
donc moi je me dis c'est absolument fou
je suis reconnaissante ça me rappelle
d'ailleurs le casteur de l'émission Ça
se trouve c'est encore une fois une
chance pour moi de sortir de ma chambre
et de voilà voilà m'affirmer dans mon
identité donc je cours vers mon mari je
suis du mais on va partir en Jordanie
c'est génial et à ma surprise il refuse
et sa famille me fait la morale sur
l'immoralité de chanter pour des
politiques
et puis là je me dis c'est vraiment stop
il faut que j'utilise la vérité à tout
le monde je me sens oppressée par lui
par sa famille et surtout par à moi-même
parce que je reste silencieuse donc je
prends quelques jours je m'isole
et là je prends une grande décision je
me dis ben je vais partir seule en
Jordanie
et je vais le quitter bon et puis
juste avant de partir je méditais aux
étoiles vraiment j'essayais de trouver
du réconfort et là j'ai une phrase qui
m'est venue et je voulais vous la
partager c'est que si tu as peur de ce
qu'il arrivera en devenant toi-même en
fait c'est vraiment en devenant moi-même
que je n'ai plus eu peur de rien donc là
j'avais peur de le quitter mais j'ai
décidé de suivre mon intuition j'appelle
mon père et je lui propose de me
rejoindre dans Jordanie parce que là
pour moi c'était trop il fallait que je
me retrouve que je retrouve la musique
et que je que je chante à nouveau et peu
importe si je perdais mon mari vraiment
ma soif d'être moi-même méritait
sacrifice et c'est d'ailleurs dans ce
dans ces grands moments de solitude que
j'ai trouvé la force raviver en moi ce
feu intérieur quand bien même il restait
vraiment qu'une étincelle c'était
suffisant pour remonter la pente et là
j'avais vraiment touché le fond je
pouvais que me relever
et j'annonce la séparation après la
prestation Jordanie et
j'avais vraiment le coeur très impacté
parce que je l'aimais voilà et dans
l'avion je commence à rédiger des
chansons notamment une qui parlait dans
cette situation d'empoisonnement d'avoir
l'impression d'être incapable de dire
non aux autres vous voyez et pourtant
cette fois-ci je m'étais dit oui à
moi-même
alors je rentre en France et j'écris un
album qui s'appelle ma voix et là je me
découvre comme artiste en suivant ma
voix ma voix eux de ma voix X
elle était enterrée en fouille par peur
que qu'elle illumine trop le passage et
là je reçois des propositions de
personnes je suis invitée à des mariages
des festivals je me redécouvre à nouveau
j'adopte des animaux je crée un
environnement qui me ressemble de retour
en France et puis je collabore je fais
des clips je suis invitée vraiment à
plein d'endroits différents dans le
monde
et là ça on pourrait s'arrêter là je
pourrais partir mais non parce que là il
y a eu une autre
péripétie je dirais c'est qu'en 2020 il
y a eu un changement et j'ai décidé de
retirer le turban tout simplement donc
du coup je vous montre à quoi ça
ressemblait dans ma tête voilà j'ai
retiré une turban en 2020
et à ce moment-là je me c'est bon mon
micro à ce moment-là je le retire et on
est
février 2020 vous voyez la scène je pars
en voyage à Madère sur une pour une
semaine c'était il y avait pas de
relation mais j'avais vraiment envie de
partir quelque part je pars pour une
semaine et là je me retrouve confiné
covid oblige trois mois donc là sur
Lille je me retrouve toute seule et je
fais ce choix de voilà je fais une
retraite spirituelle je médite devant
l'océan je me sens quelque chose de
nouveau René en moi et
j'écris un album sur la guérison
et en même temps je lis
je reçois une déferlante de message donc
à l'opposé cette fois sur mon choix de
retirer le turban donc
c'était c'était vraiment le le
l'apothéose de la situation donc là je
reçois une déférente de messages et
étrangement je me sentais pas persécuté
parce que
j'écris j'ai d'ailleurs écrit une lettre
pour l'expliquer un peu comme un poème à
l'image de cette résilience qui est née
en moi durant ces mois d'introspection
sur l'île
et cette lettre est reprise et partagée
sur les réseaux par les médias et là
petit à petit je comprends que mon envie
d'être moi-même elle dépasse mes peurs
et j'avais commencé à dessiner ma voix
en 2019 après la séparation amoureuse et
là je cheminai à présent sur la voie de
ma guérison
un peu comme un phénix puis en 2021
récemment je suis contactée par une
grande maison d'édition qui me propose
d'écrire mon livre pour raconter tout ce
cheminement de l'enfance à aujourd'hui
et là je réalise la chance le défi c'est
un défi majeur pour moi de raconter ce
que je ressens et de réveiller l'artiste
qui sommeille en moi
et donc là ce livre est actuellement en
cours d'écriture et j'ai raconté donc
mes voyages inspirants ma relation à la
musique et comment j'ai réussi à
réveiller l'artiste qui sommeillait en
moi et j'écris tout le temps voilà je
suis tout le temps en train d'écrire
et ce livre sera l'aboutissement de ma
guérison mais voilà alors parfois j'ai
des moments de doutes ça m'arrive mais
néanmoins en suivant mon intuition et
mon cœur j'ai je me suis lancée dans
quelque chose qui me faisait peur et
c'est l'entrepreneuriat donc
récemment à peu près il y a un an j'ai
monté donc je me suis lancé en
entrepreneuriat pour faire de la musique
à mon compte et je voulais vous partager
cette petite photo de nous donc c'est
mon équipe
avec qui je me déplace quand on chante
musicien et tout ça
et ça d'ailleurs anecdote cette photo
c'est une deuxième invitation en
Jordanie pour le roi alors ça c'était
vraiment incroyable c'était là il y a
deux mois j'ai à nouveau été invité par
le roi en personne pour pour chanter un
mariage
et puis voilà donc je voulais vous
partager mon histoire et vous dire
surtout que
j'ai réalisé à travers toutes ces étapes
ces épreuves que chanter ne peut pas me
quitter et ce soir je voulais vous
laisser donc sur cette question
personnellement j'ai trouvé ma voie
et vous quelle est la vôtre
merci
merci beaucoup merci
tu restes tu restes tu restes tu restes
alors dites-moi
quand on a un chanteur ou une chanteuse
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire et la santé
bien sûr alors est-ce que tu peux
chanter pour nous s'il te plaît et si
c'est possible cette fameuse chanson qui
a tout changé dans ta vie vous êtes
d'accord avec moi alléluia
si tu veux bien oui Dominique Chris on a
tout prévu mais c'est l'équipe TSE ils
sont au taquet merci alors Jérôme tu es
là est-ce qu'il est là Jérôme
Jérôme de TSR j'arrive pas à le voir
avec la lumière mais bon alors ça c'est
une équipe
tu connais ou pas
allez vas-y maintenant s'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok en fait vous êtes venu au concert de
mennel on vous l'a pas dit
écoutez pour faire rapide quand même je
vais vous faire une chanson de mon
prochain album dont je vous ai parlé qui
s'appelle guérison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et fidum il suffit
[Musique]
je suis au Mans mon kik quelques signes
avant
les réponses juste sous les yeux
alors j'ouvre mon cœur il laisse partir
la peur une fenêtre sur l'océan
renaître meilleur qu'avant et si on veut
il suffit
aux actif
je souhaite
[Musique]
ient
E
il faut
[Musique]
baby
dans ses
futurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]